you loved her in the blindside
you adored her in the proposal and
thought she was just okay and Miss
Congeniality - please welcome my
longtime dear friend and by that I mean
I've never met her
Sandra Bullock
the cinematographer known informally in
moviemaking as the DP and onset the
first friend I always make it usually
goes something like this
dude make me look good I'm serious
you got to make me look real good and
then feel free to get all artsy and
whatnot with your reverse tracking shots
you're staring scary Steadicam mishegoss
anyway
always remember job one okay these five
nominees have done real good with the
artsy part and here the nominees for
outstanding achievement in
cinematography model Fiore for avatar
Bruno del Vanel for Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince Barry Ackroyd for The
Hurt Locker Robert Richardson for
Inglourious Basterds and Cristian Vega
for the white ribbon and the winner is
model Fiore for avatar
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Mauro Fiore
first of all I want to thank the Academy
for this unbelievable honor it's a
pleasure to be here I want to thank the
visionary Jim Cameron for an amazing
vision of the film my parents
Lorenzo Romeo who came to this country
with four suitcases and a dream I want
to thank everybody in Chicago Omaha I
want to thank my crew everybody in New
Zealand une grande salute Alitalia Viva
l'Italia
Grande Bradshaw I think I forgot a bunch
of other people Jon Landau : Wilson my
crew everybody thank you very much
incredible honor thank you
ladies and gentlemen Gerard Butler and
Bradley Cooper
visual effects courtesy of the technical
wizards who make movie magic this year's
nominees offer a glimpse into the blue
people of the planet Pandora alien
refugees stuck in contemporary South
Africa and space the final frontier
here are the nominees for outstanding
visual effects avatar
Joe Lee Terry Steven Rosenbaum Richard
Benham and Andrew are joints district 9
dan Kaufman Peter Moises Robert hey Bros
and matt aitken Star Trek Roger Guyot
Russell Earl Paul Cavanaugh and Burt
stop and the winner is Avatar Joe
letteri Steve Rosenbaum Richard Berman
and Andrew R Jones
this is the fourth Academy Award and
fifth nomination for Joe letteri the
second Oscar winning second nomination
for Steven Rosenbaum the first Academy
Award a nomination for Richard Batum the
first Oscar win and second nomination
for Andrew R Jones
thank you on behalf of all of us here
avatar is a film about learning to see
the world in new ways and for that
extraordinary inspiration I have to
thank our director James Cameron Jim it
was an honor to work with you on this it
was amazing
also John Landau John you were such a
champion of the film thank you very much
for that everyone at Lightstorm who was
so helpful Eileen Moran and everyone at
wet a digital for your talent and
creativity john Kilkenny all of our
friends at Fox Sam Worthington Zoe
Saldana Sigourney Weaver all of our
great cast thank you for trusting us
with your performances I know that
couldn't have been easy to everyone
watching thank you for the great
appreciation you've shown for our film
and just remember the the world that we
live in is just as amazing as the one we
created for you
thank you
you